I love that you're a creator that has
the statues that keeps the memorabilia
you're invested there your children and
your Instagram is fascinating because
yeah you're one of us while also being
the father of the very things that
you're collecting is that something that
you've done since the image days have
you had have you collected all these
like my pets and memorabilia from the
beginning so you know it's been years
since I've covered this and I'm happy to
refresh it because this is great image
only happens because Marvel made every
character I created into a toy before
x-force was published the backstory I
remember the time of night it was at 6
p.m. summer evening the phone rang my
editor named Bob Harris said Rob just
want to let you know the toy guys were
just here and they're making all of the
x-force guys into toys I said but the
comment doesn't come out for three
months it doesn't matter they came in
they flew in to look over like what what
they would want to make toys I said
timeout Bob I just saw the first line of
x-men toys Cyclops Wolverine they they
were there was the first x-men action
figure line ever
in 1991 thank you to 91 and he said yep
and you're the second way and I go
you're skipping all of that history and
they like Rob they love bob had never
heard this either he goes they say your
stuff is really toy attic your toy attic
that's an actual work and again getting
back to the GI Joe but all that's
because my characters carried weapons
swords double edged sword okay
here is a okay so right here so this is
the he's missing his swords but this is
the shatter star from 1992 that they put
in production in 1991 before X for
someone now this is the upgrade of
shatter star that was released with the
double swords um that was released two
years ago and so obviously it's just a
newer finer more refined version and but
again dude you know I'm sitting there
drawing this stone well how do I make
you are special what says well what's
his badass more than two blades on the
same Hill right I mean and and so and
then the half cape and oh I forgot
because his um his shoulder bad fell off
and then he has a shoulder pad right
here and and look so so when they
announced that to me I'm gonna tell you
I'm like wait cable and she got her
start in Deadpool and Kane and Domino
and strive for all head of new toy aisle
and I'm gonna I so back then kids we
used phones that you held your big with
a cord and I put it back and I said I
swear to you coy I remember looking out
the window I was on the second story of
my studio and I go on a toy designer and
I remember going well I should probably
own the next toys
I should probably now that I'm not just
doing great selling comics but I have
plastic I need to you know be a toy
designer and uh because I had so many
other characters there was actually two
that I was putting into Marvel's I was
putting two characters profit was one of
them that I had for another store line
and I I reeled them back in and said you
know Marvel I've already given you like
30 characters it's a great deal that's
why I did it I knew very much what I was
doing um because of the actions of the
editorial team in the 80s you were able
to participate in action figures
royalties all of these extras that
helped contribute and make a better life
for for cartoonists and artists so we
then start image because I'm gonna own
the next stuff I do and of course the
yep there was a young bloodline of toys
there was the six-inch figures there was
miniatures there was rubber bendables
and I mean quite a year and a half later
I'm going into Mattel in in Southern
California getting the card swiped as
these giant gets smart doors open and
you go another 10 feet and you swipe the
car in another steel doors and I'm like
I'm in I'm in get smart item
where's agent 99
literally I couldn't believe the
security of these toy companies but then
they led me and they had made molds they
had made action figures of young blood
trying to woo me to get to sign the deal
and my attorney is like no you tried to
screw George Lucas you're not strong and
I was like oh this is funny this my
attorney at the time was representing
George Lucas and so he was very
protective I then took multiple bids
Todd McFarlane said all outbid everybody
I don't want the image toys leaving I
want to keep you in the fold I want you
to be companion to spawn and what works
and that's what he was able to to
collect out of all the image guys and
and he beat everybody's offer at the
time but that the image comics really
was because of the dearth of plastic and
and if you know coy like there then
would be a new cable action figure every
six months four months and that's what I
you know and and I love Sharon with
brolin like how popular cable was we've
all gotten swept up in how ridiculously
popular Deadpool was but I also read my
comments on Facebook and Twitter and
like man you give cable you Deadpool so
much love but cables my guy in and the
thing is the anniversary to x-force was
just a couple weeks ago I also quite
believe that x-force was just the first
of what would be many multi-million
selling copies and I would be eventually
knocked down to the number 10
best-selling book I mean were were 30
years later next summer 30 years in 2021
x-force is the number two best-selling
comic book of all time five million
copies Marvel went 3 million the
spider-man 5 min with x-force 8 million
with Jim and then they never sold a
million again and you go ok that had
I'll tell you why
it's right here we we had the juice we
were the guys who were turning the fans
we had great instincts there is a time
when you're simpatico with what the
audience wants and you know whether
that's the first two seasons of lost or
you know the early runs of Walking Dead
or you know the first five seasons a
game of Thrones you
just know when you're the juice is there
man and it's the give and take the back
and forth and you're exciting them so
yes I under extremely proud every time
they continue to make a new you know
Deadpool or cable and in coid there's
there's like four or five more coming
this year in a pandemic so I'm thrilled